Okay, seriously, can we talk about the
cost of living in California right now?
Like, I'm 25, working full-time, and
somehow rent eats half my paycheck
before I even blink. Groceries. Don't
even get me started. $7 for a bag of
chips, 10 [music] bucks for coffee, and
a sandwich. How are we supposed to
survive? And everyone just acts like
this is normal. It is not normal.
[music] It is insane. I love this state.
I love the vibe. But I swear California
is making it impossible for young people
to actually live here.
>> Google responded to the release of Sora
2 with their powerful update VEO 3.1.
Previously, VEO3 was limited to short
8-second [music] clips, but now with VEO
3.1, everything has changed. You can
finally create longer videos with
consistent characters, extended scenes,
stable settings, and much more. This
update makes it possible to bring your
ideas to life without being cut off
after just a few seconds, giving you the
freedom to tell complete stories and
produce videos that feel professional
for up to 3 minutes long. If you want to
know how to unlock unlimited access to
VEO 3.1 from anywhere in the world,
[music] check the suggested video on
your screen right now. It will guide you
step by [music] step to get started for
free. Stay tuned because in this
tutorial, I will walk you through
exactly how to make long videos with VEO
3.1 like the one at the start [music]
and show you why this update is such a
big deal for creators. Hit the like
button, subscribe for more AI video
tutorials, and let's dive straight into
it. So, how do you actually do it? I'll
head over to Flow, open a new project,
[music] and begin creating my video. The
first thing I need is a story. That
means having a script of what I want to
bring to life. It's not just about
generating a random script with someone
saying something. I need control, a
clear script, [music] and a story to
tell. For this example, I asked ChatGpt
to write a short text around 30 seconds
for [music] a 25-year-old female
American influencer who looks directly
into the camera while ranting about the
cost of living in California as she
[music] walks through a busy street
filled with people and cars.
To keep things consistent, I'll also ask
ChatGpt [music]
to generate a vivid description of this
influencer, including her facial
features, [music] hair color, clothing
style, accessories, and more.
Next, I would ask Chat GPT to break the
dialogue script I created into five
separate scenes. Each scene should not
only carry a portion of the dialogue,
but also include a detailed description
of the influencer and the environment
around her. That means every scene will
specify her appearance, her facial
structure, hair color, clothing pattern,
and accessories, while also painting a
vivid picture of the busy California
street she is walking through with
people moving around and cars [music]
passing by. By structuring it this way,
I can maintain visual and character
consistency across the entire video
while giving each moment a distinct
sense of setting and atmosphere.
But as you can see, chat GPT did not
follow my prompt. This means that I will
ask it to do it again.
Next, I will ask chat GPT to convert the
prompt into a JSON format. Because Veo
3.1 responds more effectively to
structured inputs than to plain text
prompts. By turning the instructions
into JSON, every detail of the dialogue,
character description, and scene setting
can be clearly defined, which helps VEO
3.1 generate longer and more consistent
videos without losing track of
characters or environments.
So, I now have my prompts prepared for
five different scenes. I'll start by
copying the first one.
After copying, I'll return to Flow and
paste it right here. This is the main
way to generate videos inside Flow.
Click on the text to video option.
[music] Choose VO3.1 fast to save
credits. Set your preferred aspect
[music] ratio. Select the number of
outputs and then hit generate. Right
after clicking, the video will begin
processing. And in a moment, it's ready.
Let me show you.
>> Okay, seriously, can we talk about the
cost of living in California right now?
Now, if you want to make the video
longer, let's say 2 or 3 minutes, you'll
need to use the add to scene option.
Once you click on it, the scene builder
opens up. This is where you can extend
your video, stretching it to several
minutes while keeping your characters,
outfits, and settings [music]
consistent.
With scene builder open, we continue by
moving on to the next prompt. I'll copy
my second prompt, return to flow, and
prepare to extend the [music] video. Pay
close attention. When extending, the
video must remain consistent. That means
the same dress, [music] the same face,
the same overall look.
Now drag the pointer to the position
you'd like the next video to continue
from. After that, click on the plus icon
to access the [music] extend option.
After clicking flow opens a smooth
transition interface. What this does is
ensure the new scene begins exactly
where the previous one ended with
complete consistency in character and
environment.
Now I paste my second prompt here and
click [music] generate.
Let's preview the new clip.
Okay, seriously, can we talk about the
cost of living in California right now?
Like, I'm [music] 25, working full-time,
and somehow rent eats half my paycheck
before I even blink.
>> One quick tip from my experience. Flo's
VEO 3.1 is excellent, but sometimes the
results are not perfect. If that
happens, simply delete the scene and
regenerate until you're satisfied.
Then I move to the next part of the text
and so on. Scene by scene, I extend and
add the new prompt, always keeping the
same character and scenario for
consistency.
Now relax and watch me create the
remaining scenes.
That's it. All five scenes have been
generated. Now, let's preview it.
Okay, seriously, can we talk about the
cost of living in California right now?
Like, I'm 25, [music]
working full-time, and somehow rent eats
half my paycheck before I [music] even
blink. Groceries. Don't even get me
started. $7 for a bag of chips, [music]
10 bucks for coffee, and a sandwich. How
are we supposed to survive? And everyone
just acts like this is normal. [snorts]
It is not normal. It [music] is insane.
I love this state. I love the vibe. But
I swear California is making it
impossible for young people to actually
live here. Okay, seriously, can we talk
about the cost of living in California
right now?
Like, [music] I'm 25, working full-time,
and somehow
like I'm 25.
>> In the end, you saw how the video turned
out. Consistent, smooth when exported.
The preview shows small pauses, but the
final export removes them. The finished
video was over 30 seconds long,
consistent with natural movements, sharp
images, and cinematic quality. To
download after export, click download.
Choose where to save and you'll have
your complete video. If you don't like
any part in the generated scene, you can
regenerate or use a video editor like
Cap Cut to cut out that part from the
project. And that's how you can use VEO
3.1 inside Flow to create long
consistent videos that go beyond just a
few seconds. If you found this helpful,
make sure to like the video, drop a
comment, [music] subscribe for more
tutorials, and check out the suggested
video on your screen to learn how to
unlock unlimited VEO 3.1 access from
anywhere in the world for free. I'll see
you in the next